time to hashtag make a scene at the
cosmopolitan of las vegas yeah you were
invited to help the hotel celebrate its
10-year anniversary
with a special photo tour and of course
cocktail
well rocky theaters is there live to
show us more rocky
hey you guys yeah come closer i have a
secret to tell you
did you know that there is an off the
menu secret cocktail at the chandelier
bar
at the cosmopolitan of las vegas and it
includes some magical flowers
all right so i'm gonna send it over to
rachel to explain the drink
and the flower but before we get to that
you mentioned a photo tour so i want to
give you the details about that so if
whether you're a tourist
or you're a local you can come on down
all year long to the cosmopolitan
to celebrate the decade of mischief you
get food packages
cocktail packages room deals too
and then of course the photo tour is
called the rose tour and your guide
candidate mischief maker rose who all
you got to do
is text her at hi rose that's four four
seven six seven three
and then she texts you and you and sends
you to each of the photo
opportunity installation so if you're
seeing those pictures they're really
cute
don't want to miss it all year round and
beyond as well so now let's get
to the verbena okay the secret drink
rachel what is this magical
potion i should call it it is a slightly
asian
uh margarita a twist on a margarita
which may just which makes it special is
the bus button
the buzz button it's a sichuan button so
when you taste it um it actually makes
your
mouth buzz almost a numbing sensation do
you hear that
so when you take a sip of your drink
okay yeah i'm gonna go ahead and taste
sip it first
okay taste the cocktail and then you
taste like a regular margarita that's
good
flour swish it around a little bit it
doesn't taste great
it never tastes good i never get used i
never get used to that okay
and then afterwards you sip again sip
again and it changes the flavor profile
of the cocktail
and now it's like a bitter i don't even
know how to describe it what are those
flavors i'm tasting uh the yuzu is a lot
of that
it's the asian inspired yuzu sour
tequila
changes its flavor as well i have to
admit
it's regular margarita style and then it
turns into something
completely completely different and
delicious so you guys have to come down
to the chandelier bar
to taste the verbena and it's not on the
menu but also there's
a ton of other drinks on the menu that
are classic that you can enjoy here at
the cosmopolitan because
you know it's 10 years after we've got
to be traditional too
yeah so let's talk about the cosmo the
cosmo has been with us all 10 years that
we've been open
uh it's our signature cocktail uh they
they went through many many recipes
before they decided on this one
with the hanger mandarin in the salerno
is his main
some lemon cranberry all and the white
cranberry kind of a different take on
the cosmopolitan
look at that look at that now guys
they've they've sold over
almost a million of the verbena so i
think it's a fan favorite
it is so come on down celebrate 10 years
of mischief here at the cosmopolitan
i'll send it back to you
i need to start hanging out with rocky
more she knows all the good spots